it is all systems go for the super bowl
on
sunday can't wait super bowl 55 ron
futrell
live in studio joining us now to talk
about the chiefs and the bucks in the
big game
here we go brian yeah we're now only
let's see i have an app for this
three days 22 hours 21 minutes 47 46
45 seconds i do for the super bowl okay
the teams have already met once this
year in fact they met in tampa bay it
was an interesting game
chiefs jumped out to a big lead early it
was patrick mahomes and tyreek hill over
and over again there was nothing tampa
bay could do to stop this combo
the bucks came back late in the game to
make it close but it's interesting the
chiefs won that game by three
and what's the spread for sunday's game
i think it's chiefs favored by three
and the old man tom brady 143 years old
he's ready to roll
give her not many people have played
at my age and um i'm i'm hoping that you
know i can
give some of that wisdom to some of the
younger younger players who
want to do the same types of things the
biggest thing is going to be me just
getting the ball out of my hands
uh getting it to the playmakers that i
have around me
they have a really good defense really
good defensive line uh linebackers
bb's kind of the whole the whole deal
and so for me just trying to make
positive plays
and this is an interesting site in tampa
they're already putting the fake fans in
those seats cardboard cutouts there will
be real fans of the game around twenty
two thousand
so they're gonna have to mingle with the
cardboard cutouts
it should keep fights to a minimum i
hope also ted tells me it's looking more
and more like it's gonna rain on sunday
so i'm guessing the cardboard pads
are gonna look more lifeless that'll be
fun to see they'll look lifeless as the
game goes on to be slumped over
um also the bucks will be the home team
on sunday not just playing at home they
will be the home team the nfl alternates
every other year
which home team is there it's the afc
here's an easy way to remember afc and
even numbered years
nfc in odd number years that started in
1967 an odd year
when the packers from the nfc being the
home team
in that game when they beat the chiefs
by the way in super bowl
no